how the Gowan brat my name is Bertha
welcome back to some more happy wheels
tell everyone it's not rape if you like
it bye
don't look back oh we can do this
together
I'll finish it without you you little
piss a alright else [ __ ] off ah right if
I got a dyrdek in his face but bun is
dick in my face never a big victory
but what are you going but
[ __ ] that I that moans [ __ ] it FA get
mad get mad about the run well why the
[ __ ] not welcome to bar on let's go
that's go whoa what are you doing with
those arms man it never works
does anyone die same Iranian as a hey
hey my peanuts peanuts come back at
goddamnit penis all right
are you so happy happy happy
all right dad love you
[ __ ] off I hate you
you smell like my boss I love me my boss
smells pretty good out today there we go
that's how I roll your daddy don't love
you
come on bike yeah my one inch is better
my deck
brutality super upswing
welcome to rub swing I never played one
of these before
Wow front slept well bounce a your
mama's [ __ ]
why did I say that god damn I died all
right there we go there we go front
flipper whoa
bouncy grabby backflip but scrab front
flip grab that front that's how I roll
oh thank you thank you thank you thank
you
all right let's keep doing some all
Asians are lame one harpoon easy all
right if it's easy then should be easy
ah all right if you make it over here
without throwing your little boy you are
pro bring it [ __ ] yet what cam oh I
admit it hey like I'm a rope [ __ ] yeah
all right you go son 11 harpoons that
sounds like a movie or something all
right so let's do this did not go as
planned
I can still dance nope what am i doing
I'm touching his deck yeah bullseye
[ __ ] ah well come back torture
that take me yeah
take away I felt good tickle my genitals
don't give a [ __ ]
it makes supersonic flow throw oh my god
is it so epic
hi hey how you done hey noob no but
that's your name you want a present
you want another one you want this one I
give you all of my presents flip a truck
stop a flash flood proof luck guess oh
I'm gonna get catch a bus
this is not good no I refuse to kill him
you can't buy my I'm on my period
god damn it is way too soon it's only
the middle of the month all right here
we go
oh my leg anthem a song using trigger
toots roommate party really all right
that sounds pretty cool everyday I'm
alright
all right nice good son you can do it
god damn how do you do it here you're
not supposed to be alright son
do you [ __ ] do what I tell you to do
alright go son go go where the hell did
he go alright let's go together
come on son you can do it buddy you're
over there get off man disgusting
got back got back right assess shut oh
no even shared traded on Bay I hate
y'all for this at all level why are you
reading this I don't know
well why you know mum come on miss me
I'm taking you with me Jennifer take it
you're wet man okay that's stupid all
right let's go stop now I'm not gonna
stop wait this wait here control I'll go
what what is going on here for this
first time you actually ah [ __ ] yeah God
all right I'm not gonna stop I'm not
gonna trust no no I don't want to go
ahead but stop
all right I forgot let's just go fast as
[ __ ]
there we go why do you even bother us
yeah I made it house don't know three
texts no I'm not gonna do it
all right fine as finishes we don't
release vespa god damn it that scared
you no I did it no stop I don't trust
what if it do it oh not so fast answer
the next question what is the mass of
Earth I think it's best foot all right I
win no I don't just kidding [ __ ] it's
that thing sliding oh after me it's like
a dead fish or something all right what
is this
dead fish why don't we go like problem
yes I have a dead fish as a leg no I
don't trust it get a keep going you and
me bad fishy
rejected captivate me and that fish are
dead
alright alright we're gonna keep going a
little bit yes I have a problem don't
reject me please
okay hold control yes yes escape or if I
want you and me leg come on leg no
chuckles like put it leg how difficult
that's really difficult all right
brother
that's all for me today I can breathe
you enjoyed watching subscribe today
don't wake your bag don't you dare wake
a day Who am I
I don't know actually what's your name
oh it's a BB
my name is clover Bert wait you are
cleverbot all this time you are clever
rod